[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello again to anyone that was on the
masa under stream earlier we got a bonus
stream today because of our man Rob
handle early handle a handler e handler
e handler hand lorry handler e we got a
cool game
we got a press preview build of
descenders you guys tell me all about
this cuz you were the one that was
excited and was like yo Tay yeah let's
do a stream on this game yeah dude um
kind of crept up on reddit first I feel
like I saw a trailer for it oh yeah
namely that you can go really fast
through trees and first-person on a
mountain bike okay and it looks intense
like I think Star Wars and or on a
speeder bike you know all right
snowy walks alright and yeah I've had
some time with it it's pretty let's just
say this is the second morning that
woken up and I've thought like I don't
wanna play more of this game oh I I
really enjoy the controls of it you have
out your bunnyhop you have your tilt
your lean and you do tricks obviously oh
God
I will get the first person I just kind
of want to show this because it is
easier to play like this first person is
more challenging but we would be dead
okay
I was thinking what's my first crash
gonna be like and that was the best one
oh my god sorry yeah no that's alright
anyway so you start at the beginning
yeah checkpoint sir yeah there are
checkpoints and you have health so this
is actually mid I'm in mid session
they're called sessions basically you
start off with like four for health or
for wrecks but if you if you wipe out
really bad that's like in case they love
dying that way yeah I mean respawning
and I want to go to an easier map okay I
had just got so you have to completely
wrecked by the way definitely you
have to you have to complete three what
they call sessions three of them on each
course to get to the next one so
currently I have three unlocked okay so
yeah your shed you get unlocks through
experience you can I got like a
leaderboard there in the bottom left on
steam this is on steam by the way yeah
it comes out early access in February I
believe February right there on the
bottom thank you
so yeah just so you guys know I'll be
tuning in to the chat to see what you
guys got you got questions for Rob I'm
sure he'll tell you how to put your head
into a jump into a wooden plank yeah
yeah this game so the thing about this
game is you know I want to say like the
modeling and the textures I think are
okay it's this game definitely has a lot
of jank and in the community they've
including the dev who reached out to us
with a preview code said that they are
constantly updating this game since I've
been playing it for two three days
they've had a few updates you can oh
shoot but what I will say is that it
controls really well and that's what I
like right off the bat you can kind of
for see yourself getting better at this
game nailed it so you can do all sorts
get it yeah what could be the tracks to
these audio tracks are pretty hot yeah
right you know can always be rocket yeah
I was just about to say yeah right like
it's got that got that feel to it you
know yeah and each course or each kind
of really I wouldn't say there are
environments and like terrain changes if
you saw I picked um this is the first
one there's like woods like redwood
woods and then I just got like a desert
one and they get harder the desert one
has a lot going on and after this course
here I'll show you what kind of wood
entails a session this is the best every
time in the end of red every time at the
end I always love to panic myself do a
baby yeah oh yeah also just so you guys
know
we have the publisher of the sender's in
the YouTube chat they are no more robots
if there's questions they'll also answer
them so send them on over the there
they're an YouTube chat right now we're
also on Twitter and GameSpot so if you
want to ask questions that's probably
good good spot to do that
definitely since Rob might not be the
most expert oh I think all my skills are
your skills are up there
my skills are novice division - down
there dude take time man ok ok so let me
explain kind of what you're really doing
I know they're gonna have more modes
down the road but ok this is what you're
basically up this is what a session is
so that essentially start here the first
one you want to get to the end or what's
called a boss jumping you gotta see it
it's a gigantic jump over a bridge yeah
now you have you have to get there and
make it without dying and so again
that's like okay web you have for wrecks
you have to basically survive now when I
go to each one of these I have a top
right there if I get 5 seconds of
airtime so if I achieve that then I get
an extra health so you can kind of if
you play well and say alright if you
make a lot or you can you know prep
yourself a lot of health now the thing
is I'm looking at now these three
options and they cut I want to say this
is procedurally generated maybe he can
attack no combat but if you look at
these maps here I'm gonna pick one that
has a lot of stunts because I wanted
John Wright as one has the most curvy
stunts as Novoa robot says ste it's
gonna be on steam early access on the
9th so if you want to check that out
that's in a couple weeks but for the
time being you get to watch Rob do some
hot stunts here in a second hopefully oh
wow so he doesn't get rekt you already
got the five seconds no I was just look
I've played see this is new to me like
they are they're updating like terrain
and like atmosphere
Oh a little double backflip you're bold
man there all right so you got five
seconds one time there yeah that was
also five seconds so you need to go so I
actually thought it was in one go but I
guess just it just totals right oh you
want to see the first person if you
believe in yourself risky good save good
save you nailed it though you got the
the little Chivo there actually yeah I
know it's multiple camera yeah that was
pretty good but first whoa doing the
flip is like terrified okay we're just
off oh so now you only have three more
wrecks yeah but you can so if you look
ekend thing I think again uh yeah you're
right right so yeah it does reset haha
wow this is a lot harder huh oh it's so
much harder yeah cuz if you obviously
are doing a flip you can't see the
ground or the horizon so you don't know
where you're gonna land do you feel any
lag or anything like that fine huh I
haven't seen anything
no are we getting lag no no people are
just saying how is the lag in the game
oh um we're what are we running on here
we have I believe there's a 1080 in
there so this rig is pretty beast yeah
so I have it all maxed out on my off on
my work computer here I have the other
770 I think in order to get a nice
stable framerate I had to turn down some
of the ternary terrain and shadows but
uh that's pretty fine be pretty
intensive depending it's just like all
those the extras bells and whistles if
you want I'm sure the the hands thing
that you see in the first person really
makes me think of virtual reality so
someone was like this could make a
awesome
it's so funny yet so every person in the
office was walked by my desk has asked
that or said that is it in VR and the
email we got also addressed that the
first email and I think they can even
confirm but they said that they a bunch
of them tried in the office like a test
build of the art and they all got really
really really sick yeah and I'm sure
they're not gonna understand they're
gonna figure it out if it works or not
for me are but down the road looks
pretty fun hey what's up Pierce the cat
he said hey hey hey Rob the music as the
young people would say is lit hashtag
lids sorry
is there any are there more tricks other
than flips and spins Rob yeah I'm not so
I just have master of those two but you
can you can do well I guess you any cook
yeah any kind of mixture of those two so
you could do something like that oh boy
I'm not very good at it you kind of put
yourself in a okay and they're in a
sticky situation
yeah where you know it's kind of hard to
recover so you want to keep it kind of
simple but I'll try that again
oh not God oh so the other thing too is
yeah you've you depending on how high
you are you have to land on a ramp Oh
or else you'll wreck okay screw degree
like
no tricks the soundtrack is from weekly
city liquid city as no more robot said
also Hassan had said that it's a drum
and bass or boss label awesome dig in
the dig in the teams so you have like a
break for a skid for likes you know more
like just CAD tight turns but then you
also have like it's like it's like a
tilts uh-huh so and we'll get to the
next kind of environment later but the
tilt is got left by the way so you
better do one of these objectives good
point but yeah I'm having a pretty good
time with it it's it's fun it's I'm
still getting like an enjoyment in first
person like how intense intense it is
it's definitely a scarier experience for
me watching it's a because I have no
control and wait until you get till you
start doing this through trees it's
freaking exhilarating there we go baby
up trying to do 360 up then do that
Oh
it is not on VR at least not for now
because the test bill that they had
according to rob made them a little sick
so I'm sure if they decide to go that
route there's you know I'll figure it
out
I would assume that they would I don't
know if they're gonna bring this to
console but that's probably their next
steps my opinion Oh risky oh yeah do you
do a front-flip yeah a class and I could
I kind of do what feels good you sixteen
just you and the dirt baby oh yeah you
got it you got it
so now you just got survived this run
and you'll get an extra wrecked so yeah
you can like in some of these courses
you need to stick to the road I could
just go like right for the finish line
right now some people that know what's
up with the pipe so there's SAF is
talking about bikes I don't even know
what what they are wait how do you like
my fix going you're killing your
reputation bro yeah it's kind of worth
it though yeah you love this contract
apparently pricey DLC isn't their thing
so good on you guys
this is it don't get scared now they
these melons are definitely not my
melons beautiful animal but I wouldn't
dare ever do this my body is too frail
yeah initial within 35 seconds Rob
that's the ball here
so what there we go what's that with a
big boss level here we're gonna get to
it oh come on sorry for yelling
yes unless some of the motion controller
I'm not really looking a chat but
currently is more or less the only way
you can play this game so you need a
controller they are working on like
keyboard controls that being said it's
Oh dip we doing it you asking me how
your fit is I think it's ugly
you just got purple polka dots you're
wearing yellow shorts oh we're in the LA
Laker colors how can I ever condone that
Robert pretending like I was just
talking about fashion in Monster Hunter
and I think your fashion is poor your
descenders fashion is poor look at that
gross chat a great fan this looks I look
good
dude I look good you intimidating look
like ever got to get rekt man you're
right I really am losing some reputation
there uh so let's back out okay because
because I'm on that was one session you
kind of play until you drop it's gonna
make me go back to that first area but I
don't want to do that I want to go into
that one Centauri says that speed ramp
whoa I feel the adrenaline so also Eric
if you want to just hone your skills and
get you know
shred the gnar even though there's no
large shred do a little warm-up you got
some the shed oh wow
okay true story and it pissed me off you
know that a little wheelie you did there
I was going I was driving to my
girlfriend's house somewhere in the
mission and I made a right turn on a
kind of narrow street a group of kids on
bikes good come in the opposite way of
my car one of those kids was popping a
wheelie like really close to my car and
he barely avoided it and it freaked me
the hell out because I was terrified
that I was gonna hit him and I had
nowhere to go
he literally almost at the last minute
swerved out of the way I honked my horn
at him that shows how old I am
go to school shouldn't you come on put a
helmet on shouldn't you be in school
alright alright build that trail man so
like this area
with the steepness cranked all the way
up have you done it on eight steepness
soak it in also a chat tell me what's up
what your thoughts are on his ugly ass
bit I said it I'm ready where you might
have some framerate problems uh for the
early access is it free other night or
is it uh do they have to purchase it
someone's asking ok I'm sure no more
robot old well answer I'm oh my lord you
are freaking me out Rob oh man [ __ ] a
sick buddy up there to save my life
ok this is pretty cool this is a lot
cooler than just doing the jumps this is
actually mildly terrifying as just the
viewer that has no control over the
sticks and we're just listening to this
calm serene Houston look at that no hits
no Falls
except for that nice nailed it all right
so let's see here finished within 35
seconds Wow
so it's $25 with a launch discount thank
you Scott Holly it's not really a racing
game but we're definitely going to be
doing some tournaments post-launch
sick oh alright alright what are we
doing so you know you guys think ahead
right if I want to do this in 35 seconds
I'm gonna want real steep with not much
curve or stunts okay you're going 6/8
steep huh now I'm gonna go in order to
do this you I'm gonna have to go off the
track
okay meaning you do you meaning this is
about to get real sticky real real
sticky real hairy and it's at night
oh where vision visibility is very poor
is it um are the maps in terms of time
of day
OOP geez is it always like nighttime on
this level or is it just random it's
random oh yeah it's really really random
this is even this is crazy I'm surprised
you're not doing this at first person
Wow near-miss I'm coming
[Music]
we are good time really no time 24 out
of 35 I thought you were calling for
time like a speedrun or wood like that's
the end time I was like wait what we're
at the end or not you got three seconds
you got three seconds and that is so
difficult
no you chickened out oh are you do it
again I can't I got to keep moving
yeah keep moving alright alright do a
double backflip so I'm gonna want I'm
gonna want some steep and some stunts
here it's definitely not a gun game
pitiful animal do one double backflip I
dare ya they're tough so you're gonna
need speed and you're gonna need a
really nice jump a fun fact from no more
robots the nighttime level was inspired
by spelunky oh that's cool I'm curious
what spelunky twos gonna look like like
what are they changing because we
obviously only got that kind of like I
wouldn't I'm not really cinematic
trailer but you know it had no gameplay
oh so I'm interested to see you wow just
my bones creaked a little bit from that
I've been telling people this game is
like what would happen if if I like act
if a buddy of mine who's like a pro
bound bit biker was like come on man
just like one one day let me show you
the ropes I'm like fine he's like it's
easy to go blue a bunny slope now go out
there and then this is me
oh come on oh good good slow down really
weren't any jumps on that one that's
fine you're on your last hand okay I can
do this but I picked you got it one life
to live
oh you know what this one is what's up
there we go
I think this is just a straight yeah
you're going 70 85 mile Killah km/h here
95 holding a static and you're dead
literally you're literally dead yeah I
agree since I've literally dead well on
the plus side they could put my dead
body in some ether calm sighing pants
Westy it's not gonna be out for a couple
weeks it'll be on Steam early access
down the ninth I believe they said $25
but there's gonna be a launch discount
yeah you can wish list it as no we're
robots has mentioned man I should have
brought my dead very dead so dead it's
not that hard Bojangles uh it takes some
time to get used to though that's thing
but what's what's cool is that like I
it's one of those games where the
controls you can just tell us are so
well defined that you just immediately
go oh okay I can see myself getting
better like without a doubt so that's
what's kind of neat to like you're
having fun like off the bat
a boss special mark jump partial rice
has been Meijer one yeah so like all
these like areas or sessions will
culminate into like a almost like boss
level of which you have to conquer oh my
lord
sorry where you have to do something so
the last the first area Rob had to jump
over a bridge as like the kind of boss
level here so this is cool that you can
kind of just like make your own track
yeah yeah more or less
the and the boss of the as I was saying
earlier if I wanted to get to the next
area which is desert I have to complete
three sessions in order to move on and
get that area now the thing is though is
that boss jump that we were talking
about yeah every time you get harder
because you're being tasked something so
the first time is just to land it second
time it's like do a flip there times
like do a 360 so it gets more more
difficult got it alright I'll do the
linking of the game just in case so that
you guys don't get like kicked or
timeout timed out and that way
that way everything is all good in the
hood let me put this in there
boom send that over to the twitch chat -
boom
being us all for tuning in checking out
the sector's a little early we're going
off-roading right now then some sick
tricks as we make our way down the
racetrack oh I'm not doing now I got
your fries
I'm sorry I do clean landings okay
where's the road you're just not even
worried about going on there I need the
road for a jump but how about we just
chill with that person yeah
hey what's up I spilled hot dogs
or campsite what you get for doing
tricks off-road this is exactly what I
get
dang for 60 bruh there you go now jeez
thought you're gonna eat it doing
something stupid
well the funny is when he makes a noise
he goes woohoo
and then you just nail a tree
immediately do a barrel roll I don't
appreciate you can't do it I think you
can't really yeah so much for cleaning
century the fast speeds in first person
got me cringing and edging at the edge
of Earth and at the edge of my seat
same here so which uh which area are we
in right now is this a second course
this is the second area it's worse I
don't know what the fourth one is maybe
um
no we're robots and we're robots connect
and you got it so yeah we posted the
links no VR yet might not even be in the
cards to be honest oh yeah I mean I'll
let them speak to that yeah I mean it
sounds like I'm in real sick probably
like yeah not right now prepare the
trush gotten for near-misses there for
near-misses okay
you find yourself going for the bonuses
a lot yeah okay I mean yeah you get more
experience you get what does the
experience give you gear you do anything
that you draw cosmetic I think they
mentioned in a in it I don't know in the
community like blog that that was the
plan later on yeah was that like Mike's
especially will have stats Oh like
handling or like better jumping there's
no like that of speed yeah there's a
near-miss fourth area is Peaks
thank you man huh looks fun but watching
this is making me want to spew that kind
of happened to me a little bit above all
it's one of those things where sometimes
when you're not the one playing it it's
kind of houses I don't know what I'm
supposed to do it makes it tough but uh
what I've been doing is I just kind of
look at chat see what's up with you guys
and then I come back and take a gander
how about this views this is their rank
to see you better yeah there's ranking
nice okay I'm twelve
so is it like score attack kind of style
we're like you want to be someone else's
four or I think so I'm not too sure
about that okay well that's what we have
no more robots in the chat for Ben Myers
one is like in this one the most view
wise give you the huge fov yeah the
camera work on these is as good yeah I
agree
oh boy okay oh and a little wheelie
after okay that wheelie was an
unintentional boat ad we got a fancy
over here framing us a little rough on
this view though okay all right there
there are a few different rankings is
what a no more lots of Sonic's
specify what's the dream
what's your dream do not I had a dream
to not hit a tree the main one is
leaderboards or who has the highest rate
right and standing I don't know I'm
waiting for him to fill it out good work
there
you got no near miss is the main Mello
curvy little curvy
okay Kevin is saying the camera movement
is done really well yeah I agree
as this were the switch no it's not a cc
or not no ha no ha Pro Mode Pro Mode
just me in the woods in my bike
oh yeah oh no wait it's a double Oh
nailed it that was risky nailed it
so good now into the world we pal
spirits are you listening
[Music]
it's a dream dream full of trees it's
actually a game oh okay screwing it
we're totally cool baby Oh rock rock
rock yeah I got rock all right let's
let's see the UH the desert okay let's
go to the desert we got flatline green
bike the desert is pretty cool it's got
it's got a lot of stuff so in regards to
the multiplayer question it sounds like
depending on how well the game sells
there may be experiments with
multiplayer which is cool Oh Erik
remember when I said I was 12
yeah I'm now I'm ten okay well you know
maybe if you didn't lose all those rep
points you hired Canyon at desert Oh
Canyon into the canyons we go out do one
double backflip the problem no problem
use the beams to keep momentum through
the turns use the beams
[Music]
maybe those wooden beams and stealth
rock yeah that rock came out of Noah's
still rock that rock came out of nowhere
yeah we're currently playing on a
computer Michael is gonna be on scheme
on February 9th early access it's gonna
cost $25 but it's gonna be a launch disk
can see happening out nail it's no
problem
Oh save Oh not save still saved Oh
nailed it we're good rock phantom rocks
back on it are we good
I think this Mac has the best music so
far Oh was it was it level specific yeah
Oh buddy ha ha do a double backflip I'm
gonna do it right here dude all right do
it looks like a high enough jump to get
that done yeah here we go yeah no
problem problem well oh my god can you
imagine doing this real-life yeah I
can't I probably dead no drug it away
it's gonna be on PC first for sure and
then I haven't heard anything else but
steam early access in about three weeks
apparently the final sounds aren't even
in this built just yet
oh good we'll have amazing sound effects
from power up audio awesome yeah I was
gonna say because it seems like only
just a few different tracks like you
know I mean like it just like tire on
dirt can be some gears just posted a
single again in chat in case you're
curious of where to get the game
Oh No what good
you love opera with my challenge yeah
well you don't have to do that challenge
that's just up to you if you want to
live with the need for speed here I
think is a bad idea I think this is a
bad idea I think you're supposed to go
down that Canyon but maybe this is the
shortcut yeah don't need brakes
[Music]
that would hurt oh you're crazy me I
think your first shot you is better than
that last strategy you break the ready
damn it
[Music]
oh you what are you asking uh just gonna
say like you're crazy for doing that
little hop you get there baby
pelipper says 50 kilometres per hour
seems like a hundred plus does ya ask
once you kind of get going
oh damn it we're so dead Oh wasting all
right I'm gonna point for real I play
for real okay three sixty two times I
can do this okay change the track CNN
O'Neill's thinks this looks so sick I
hope you uh get your hands on it seeing
when it comes out
thanks for tuning in all right we're
gonna let Rob he's really gonna show you
how eSports he is at descenders I'm
gonna quit my job and go pro okay they
said they did say they're gonna have
some tournaments so you know I would
love to see some like really high level
Wow how am I supposed to land that by
being eSports maybe if you were more
eSports you would have landed that
there yeah it's I'm sick
oh you're gonna give us a little
hilarious watching we're out there yeah
look we're still going I know right I
know so the other I was like oh [ __ ] and
then a cactus like no no no I thought
you were gonna go see I know I just when
the music book got turned off right all
right
serious time
reminds me a lot of like pendulum why
why I like it
[Music]
you didn't do anything good now what's
up Minister Narwhal eight seconds of
airtime all right so we're gonna want
some steepness and some stunts just so
you know you're on your last day it's
true
well that was intentional cuz I want to
feel alive
[Music]
good luck
bang 8 seconds of airtime yeah that's a
lot
[Music]
nice jump line up whoo bad idea
oh no problem oh you got two of eight
there I fell a lot longer than two well
it just is two out of eight so maybe you
have to go at any time
Oh real that one
[Music]
no breaking no problems see this you
if you want to check out the forest
minister you just all you got to do is
scrub back on the DVR we'll go to for us
after this and you can check that out
like I want you to get to the scammer
works you get to the peeps man once you
get good and get to the peace that would
take three times three sessions oh
really
yeah it takes a while I was saying
earlier I was like damn like I got to
desert which took me that's when you're
supposed to ride backwards we're not
sure how many total areas there are we
know that there's four T's for oh
there's only four yeah currently okay
great
nailed it this is this doesn't seem as
intense though like I'm not as afraid
when I see this cuz maybe I can see
everybody now okay yeah now I'm
terrified
100% terrified Oh red all right eight
seconds of air time again your bales are
beautiful all right let's do it
yeah four types of maps but they're
procedurally generated yeah yeah like so
you like you really are never playing
like the same Oh No Road oh this one
only needs that a sec OH
cacti you're gonna go to the top part of
it I don't okay I don't know what's
thinking good luck to you sir oh I dare
you
I dare you look at me that's pretty cool
dude
oh because there's no road there's no
checkpoint I guess you are crazy
dang it I want to be good
[Music]
James's has a worthy successor to
domination and it Wow faceplant wasted
oh oh that's a dead I think you'd be
area that would be a de a de dead mr.
foreskin alright dude your ranks gonna
go down bro
it's a tough world out there Oh bull for
a life 99 early-access
with a lawn Dupree before launch
discount is gonna be 25 but there's
gonna be a launch discount so I'm not
sure what that percentage is yet but it
is on the steam store for you to add as
a your wish list if you want and it'll
be out on early access than that this is
what looks it looks like when you write
it's not you look okay
that keeps getting bright I got
something let's take it I think people
need to tell you how ugly your 42
I don't know what hat I guess cats
teacher be your rear horn or a light
again I was looking at the cat they're
just talking about how these different
types of light yeah french fries yeah
french fries are you happy now yeah
oh you've match better you got that 424
yellow and purple are caught couple
married colors there but they are but
that's the LA Lake Show I hate the
Lakers outfit looks fine just fine kappa
face great i like fries i like pricey
it's on okay oh look at that shirt need
some ketchup oh you're right my helmet
should been red here we go
two front flips
[Music]
okay all right here we go this is it you
technically got the front foot diet
again I think you're gonna die again
come on guy queues drifting to the right
when you're doing the flip so you might
want to start farther on the left maybe
at the ramp to compensate there you go
I don't know what that is all right
great
all right
screw it oh wow
I did not think that was gonna work so
cool if I like did that by campfire and
like grab the hot dog look I'll be
taking that I was hungry and then then
drop the dollar yeah what you think this
is Costco how much you gotta do one more
flip phantom Rock fell to rock out of
nowhere
fresh session fresh start finish without
breaking take you're diggin this music
yep more so than your racing skills oh
my oh bottom guys we got them I'm just
kidding I probably do way worse does not
look like a necessarily easy game
no braking oh I don't know why that made
me think of happy gilmore there for a
second but you know how he makes that
one shot through though oh yeah no
braking Rob everyone's really coming
around to uh well I'm not dog
yeah nice work and for the Fisher oh and
I got a help this is gonna be it this is
gonna be a good session no comment on
console exclusive smiley face isn't that
like I'm not gonna go
all right he's gonna be dangerous here
all right okay Oh stijn Koster says come
on now Mike must be calling out the
normal robots guy let's come to the weed
all right this is gonna be really tough
that's it yeah oh good top speed of 70
no problem here we go
apparently the teeth
you need to get seventy miles you're
chickening out come on you should just
bomb the run come on man you're like a
little devil on my stud don't don't
chicken out there it's like you had a
like a Ferrari and then he decided to
like just drive local just just drive to
the gas station yeah Mart it is fun like
to get to master the skid and it's he'll
ting like when to use those combinations
like geographic oh yeah dude this is the
session right here man six session six
six six six six six six
no if you I found a way to like get rekt
there I would have slapped you 20
although my name is pronounced a bit
more like Stein just throwing that out
there
okay Stein Stein sorry whatever Ivan
Sims Tim Stein will go a Stein alright
if I butchered your name I asked
I don't you guys need to do that every
day on a stream put your at least one
person's name what's up I don't think
I've ever done a 720 well you're about
to need a lot of speed
Oh
Wow here's your chance
nope oh you chickened out I there's no
way not even here dude oh yeah by for it
didn't count huh I landed I surprised
you landed that though never mind
- you left with you oh ok so wow you are
a bold man short bridged or I'm talented
this app you're gonna go back yeah
nice a nice break day here we go hold
that speed up across the bridge
whammy losing all my health I want to
get to the end screw it now do it one
more time
nope
I know I don't anymore speed I can't do
this yeah
yet you tried dangerous alright okay
here enough for two backflips I can do
that
give me a just give me the course no
stunts sometimes this happens I feel
like though little con effects I feel
like sometimes the challenge is just
impossible curves probably do it
actually
you like the song yeah all the jams are
pretty good so far
cool I just wanted to show off that you
can change the tracks
it says it right at the bottom Rob yeah
it does huh all right you know you know
I don't need the HUD you're exactly
right
just me and the forest these hot tracks
all right let's do it
no I don't want to yeah this is first
this perspective over that goal to back
to backwards in your curve
nope oh you always actually found a way
I thought for sure you're his hitting
that uh Wow
thing is though I don't even know if
that county wall that's it did yeah of
course it did so you get for being so
damn fancy with your no HUD no HUD for
life
no sorry
David likes his races with some curves
to it oh no stop dude oh my god
smells good
I have no idea the road is
Donita
finish line
got the same color
you're not gonna accomplish here - I did
did I not find out does it does it track
it from like did is it track each death
though I wouldn't finish yeah I guess I
got really did one yeah that's all right
well that is boss level boss level oh
that's easy
no no it no get the speed isn't the
issue it's like when I have to do a
trick off the boss jump because this
one's through a fire tower or Watchtower
okay this you can you do it I'm doing
the first person okay
bold man
[ __ ] alright still good had some rocks
was life
way more y'all maybe you'll get here
open over all right you really do need
to beat on this one all right well
you're gonna get that speed
yeah on the last step that nice finisher
up so what happens now you do it again
well technically this is still a session
yeah three times right I would need I
have yet to do in the desert now I have
not done a whole session on this so what
I haven't seen is what the colostrum
looks like on this maybe we can try to
get there yeah we'll give it one set of
like lives remember to depend on how
yeah I'm crazy you play sure I'm not
gonna get there now so I do you know you
don't believe dude do two 722 times
again extra life to 720s I can't even do
one you can ride off the top of that
tower if you're good nailed it nailed it
I'm so calm - you just don't even want
to take that huh jump
he said f it damn is my jam
how do I skip Oh Stein [ __ ] clearly we
are because we can let them he must have
just saw a nail the top of this we're
good or you're good all right
great job there right at the end
besides Rickon finish line like goal
post hope you die here alright yeah
someone lowered that
[Applause]
if you can make it with no no yeah you
gotta believe all right well the real
mellow real mellow is gonna be easy I'll
do I finish without baked breaking Rob
easy peas this probably is the easiest
one you know what maybe I saw this Paul
Theroux L I don't know who row L is but
I'm guessing he also jumped into the
same goal post
cool that was that's cool hear that
they're gonna update sound effects I'd
like there are being one of the devs who
had the same thing happen on Xtreme four
months ago
well how does it feel to not be alone
Rob I held back inhale
I think this is the run man I think
they're gonna make it through the desert
at least one time finish low fifty
seconds eight steepness if you pick
something easy then right if you need to
finish in 50 seconds oh wait you you
would want to get there as fast as
possible [ __ ] good tech I'm looking
at you surviving right now man I don't
think I'll be able to do it
we have little faith of yourself Oh
Rowell is even in here to defend himself
yeah you can add some extra rotation in
the air with the right stick for that
sweet 720 don't give him any ideas right
now rose
Oh No without like your a helmet that
fell off the floor they're probably the
price on PC Ryan GEOINT 525 dollars but
there's gonna be a launch discount so
alright Rob I'm gonna give you at most
two sets of four lives to get through
this session okay okay we should go back
to desert town yeah we're going to
desert us we're in a desert
oh my dukes on here yeah I know who is
brings back smell him on the Facebook's
no he's like a DJ guy okay apparently
Rowell is not real it's rule rule thanks
for stopping by and glad to hear that
Rob's not the only one that finds a ways
to lose at the finish line
hey man that's part of the game is sweet
bales sweet bales more like sweet bales
I can do two front flips that's not
problem I do that my sleep
jam right here you got a win
I need like a jump joshua heart not sure
but we've got the devs and i said the
publisher Wow that was a so maybe they
can answer you but it'll be on Steam
early access on February the 9th you
want to check it out oh I give you two
chances and you do something silly like
that
oh damn did I lose to healthcare Rameses
B says hey it's my toon smiley face is
it your toon
pretty sweet damn sweet sweet tune
actually hola
Santiago welcome oh come on he almost
did it again roll that jump in the end
there all right
one double backflips Wow you got that
that's fine
oh it is Rameses he's in here everyone's
here everyone's here
my mom's in there no she's not no she's
that cheers from the whole day of tuned
we're all tuned in having a blast thanks
for stopping by rule and thanks for
making this fun game that Rob I like it
enjoys can't wait to see more updates
down there oh nothing you it's
definitely fun right now so excited to
else going on those up it was a
nosewheel a stoppie
maybe maybe some hamburger shorts for
this yeah sure the courses are
definitely getting more complexity oh
yeah
what you have to see when you get that
high up you have to hit well that's so
good my handle bars in my neck I think I
would be good
nope oh I want it on the switch ill
eventually ding on everything those hot
updates here dad thanks to the dead sea
that's a tomb in devs of dissenters the
game we're playing you guys didn't know
that already
every Friday see y'all Nani
Ramsey's be hopefully I'm saying your
name right I feel like I found a way to
push her that one to you so please
continue to correct me if I'm saying
your name wrong I can only see what's in
chat and then I try to like like do the
Japanese ways like ro motivation or
whatever okay last name oh man all right
all right here I'll give you two more
after this that's three in total that's
it though that's it dad
and then it's bedtime
that's fair Oh drats
[Music]
there weren't different colored bikes
Samuel Nell kind of earned them though
did you did you have something that let
you change the color of each white I
didn't notice that if you did you can
change the color of the mask no no okay
so right now if there are bikes don't do
it good Rob oh that's okay are you on
your last Dan for this am i I'll give
you two more chances it's fine but
should I try it with fifty second hey
you are the master of your budget not me
I'm here to read chat and to hazel for
poor outfit choices this one's better
than I I'm digging this one more than
no you playing a fireman yes James there
are different camera angles or views
right now Rob is in this view but
there's also crazy first-person view
which I would tell them to switch tube
but okay he's just going for it no
problem no problem
oh how are you alive save it don't waste
the opportunity that the game just oh my
god alright this is it this is for reals
is for real I'm not gonna do these
challenges I'm just gonna get to the end
because I want to see what the boss jump
is sweet I pronounced it correctly thank
goodness I butcher - got one right third
time was the charm
Pemex says finally something made a good
mountain bike game oh wow that speed
yeah Rob's a crazy man not intentional
oh yeah I do love rocks
oh he yeah that's fine I wanted to take
a little nap you know first person is
the way to go so George hit then that's
how we're gonna fight alright that's how
we're gonna do it first person is
glitter is it is so nuts and Louie eater
games are it is freaking so much harder
like you know because I mean you just
you see stuff later than you would any
other way you know I mean like
because of the height like it went it
the cameras higher up or see a rock okay
so rules and Stein's names are Dutch so
he's cutting me some slack for from
mispronouncing and think he's a rat even
french fries need cigarettes oh that was
the first race goddamn it alright dude
we just started over yeah I finished
fifth in 50 seconds straight race you
got to be able to do that 50 seconds
right no way saying you up for failure
that's great yeah I'm not doing that
hey you are you can go to get help back
if I like did just an accumulation of
like cool tracks or something like that
playing it safe playing it cool
playing it safe it's a straight race man
nothing could go wrong I got sort of
like 90,000 our ones in the forest I had
peed my pants
oh we're getting there Rob we're at 67
oh wow
told you you didn't believe all right we
got a help back to near-misses don't
even try that just tell ya dude we got
three lives man yeah you're right we got
a chance here to get to that boss yo
you're right all right
[Music]
[Music]
oh man okay we love that no Hut I do
love the no hug
well
[Music]
save it Rob payment are we good we're
good
apparently it's gonna be on switch later
this year shut the hell up
that's what this says
no more robot said that Oh save it
feeling good about this - yeah you like
obsession yeah I feel good about it same
here all right it's some good here we
got what's Oh mellow straight race real
easy you know I could probably do two
360s - no no you okay that's up to you
I think I want I think I do get to the
boss show I think I can by doing this
but isn't it like is there any jumps no
but there are like little areas that you
could try doing it off you just have for
wrecks you know so I'm like wondering
should just you know all right you're
right but I also alright try once then I
mean like go for it on one on one life
and then I just need the perfect jump
this is a mellow racetrack
ginger Whizzer don't worry it's gonna be
out very shortly three weeks early
access team I'll put the Lincoln again
shortly for you to check out if you want
to put on your wish list
[Music]
nope I'm glad I did not do it there that
would benefit ah here we go
boss jump plates a boss jump what is it
Joshua heart saying like a rider myself
when you can't go riding one day or
worse break a bone and get stuck in I
can just play this game man that is a
good video this is it survive the boss
jump
can you do it Rob oh yeah what is that
are we going off the hill or the cliff
find out I'm gonna find out ladies and
gentlemen sit what why didn't you make
it it's not it's not this thing that
yeah okay we're gonna check him out of
that jump game right no style here all
safety oh my god
that was karma from Nam maybe taking
that first jump real talk
are you gonna avoid this thing to you
the oil rinsing yes I am what are your
sights here yes oh there it's over the
canyon and through the woods easy peasy
lemon squeezy all right
first person yeah I think so yeah
there we go we should wish this wish Rob
why haven't you got it I always do bad
yeah it's cuz you check it I want it to
kill yourself dang it you sure that you
should have made those other jumps I
don't know what the launch sale is James
Madison Oh oh cool I thought you said we
had to be no so I totally forgot you you
keep going on your run on your run but
if I were to permanently get this area I
have to do that desert one for ya and
we're gonna shred the actual nard
hi Oh get out of here off a little bird
should I do it bunny hop I don't know
you get your head chopped off ha ha ha
we broke your game broke your game ha ha
broken fix it my head should be two
miles away all right I I guess I just go
forward no hub you got do it that was
tight that was really tight
I don't know how much it'll be off how
much the percentage sale is
unfortunately game sure someone in one
of the devs or Nomar a robot could speak
to that if they want to if not you just
have to find out donate the rock gonna
have two more Rex come on yeah right
right now Rodimus Prime no I should play
it really safe she says that as he says
that at rule collision detecting on
holidays when we called oh my lord
Rob I'm praying I'm freaking you can't
break on the edge spazzing Nate they
tried it they tried a build in VR and it
kind of got them sick so they're gonna
either refine that or maybe table that
for the time being the probably gonna
just work on making this assault
game experience first but again the devs
are in YouTube chat so they could speak
better to that I'm not gonna put words
in their mouth or anything like that at
the end box it's fire it's a helicopter
so I gotta jump and Danny picking up see
ya they're gonna know the running mate
alright two front flips live yewah I
think two
either I think it like I can do this I
can do sliding can help you reduce
speeds this time
oh sure
waiting okay yeah luck to you thanks
last standby though man
no rose it go go here got a waypoint on
the top are we going down are we bombing
this this hill here just think this is
like breath of the wild your shield
boarding okay oh why would you do this
[Music]
rekt so you I'm get you can't come back
right I can't go back to that here quick
quick restart oh dang it dang it Rob
alright you want to call it there then
sure
alright well appreciate you guys all
tuning in to our kind of preview stream
here of descenders thanks to the devs
and no more robots I think the publisher
for stopping by chatting with the rest
of the folks in chat and talking to us
it was it was a fun time we appreciate
it
looks fun Rob's gonna probably play some
more once that early access comes out it
comes out February the 9th launch
there's gonna be like a launch discount
so I think it's $25 not sure what the
launch discount is but I'll put the
steam link in chat so you guys can check
that out fun little game here weird yeah
Rob just finds ways to die but all right
thanks Rob for playing one last death
okay one last death what are we doing
are we going out on a bang yeah let's go
I add okay that's what we got a
first-person first-person it no huh no
HUD full game not us this is it
embrace the speed
[Music]
it went alright thank you guys so much
you later they draw
[Music]
[Music]